okay so welcome to session three and I
hope you have a good lunch my name is
una Karuna car I'm a physician and was a
humanitarian worker for more than two
decades
mostly with well mostly with the medical
humanitarian organization called Doctors
Without Borders from 2010 to 2013 I was
its international president currently I
am a senior fellow at the Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs here at
Yale now before I introduce the speakers
and the topic I I just want to take one
or two minutes to sort of introduce or
one of the programs that we're working
on here so under the ages of the
McMillan center so Professor Kushner and
I along with other faculty members from
across the various schools and centers
working to set up a multi-country multi
disciplinary survey of forced migration
in some of the top host transit and
settlement countries so this network
what we are loosely calling resonant
will be the first ever effort to
understand refugee choices and decision
making across the entire arc of the
migration experience so this will
involve the development and application
for example of standardized and
validated quantitative and qualitative
research methodologies to gain a much
better understanding of the refugee
experience and and this will hopefully
help us fashion better humanitarian
responses as well now one key objective
of the rough net and you heard Jody
Nelson speak earlier today one of the
key objective of resonant is to bridge
the gap between the formal international
architecture of humanitarian aid and
local
civil society organizations while
they're led by communities or
individuals or people affected by the
crisis themselves in in 2015
the last year for which we have
information a record twenty eight
billion dollars were spent on
international humanitarian assistance
yet a mere 0.2 percent of reported
humanitarian funding was allocated to
local agencies so 28 billion was spent
on humanitarian assistance 0.2 percent
went to local agencies but the grand
bargain which Jodie talked about earlier
aims to achieve a global aggregated
target of at least 25 percent of
humanitarian funding to local and
national responders as directly as
possible by 2020 so we've got three
years left and they want to go from zero
point two to 25 percent so you can you
can just begin to think of some of the
problems associated with it so one of
the things that we want to do at breadth
net is to create a global network of
practitioners and researchers that can
provide leadership and build local above
capacity whilst advancing knowledge
innovation and thought leadership so RAF
net will hopefully raise the profile and
capacity of local level organizations to
embed a new norm in humanitarian aid
where local level organizations are
considered equal partners which they are
not at the moment
very often rather than as the last
recipients of a long chain of funding
RAF net will hopefully rebalance this
relationship by putting the emphasis on
learning from scholarship and practice
thereby improving the capacity of
practitioners to better access knowledge
and finance to deliver effective and
accountable assistance so it's a you
know it's a ambitious sort of project
but what I want to underline is that
this is going to be a multidisciplinary
effort so those of you who are
interested
should get in touch with either cavae or
myself and we will be working with other
universities and other practitioners in
other countries and hopefully pooling
our resources together we will be able
to help build the capacity local
agencies to access funding from the
international system and and and spend
it the best way possible for their own
for their own needs so this sort of
effort I hope you'll agree is crucial
for countries to rebuild lives and
livelihoods and also for individuals to
safeguard their dignity and agency so
the panelists we have today will reflect
on some of the challenges involved in
rebuilding societies and systems and
particularly we will focus on health
systems we have three professors from
the Yale School of Medicine and they
will talk about three very distinct kind
of experiences and and and very
interesting programs as well but I've
also asked the families to reflect on
the necessary conditions essential
ingredients if you will for
post-conflict rebuilding to happen and
also because the symposium is titled the
next generation of humanitarianism and
refugee studies I've also asked the
panelists to comment on areas that need
further research and support and how the
new McMillan program can work towards
addressing these areas so you know as a
university I think we should do some
putting our heads together and see what
areas we need to focus on what our
priority areas so I hope we can start
that conversation I won't go into the
detail bio of of the three panelists you
can look it up and in the book the first
speaker is dr. Oscar rustic I will focus
on Wanda's post genocide building of the
healthcare system
dr. Christina Talbert Segal will talk
about liberius efforts to rebuild a
resilient healthcare system in the
middle of the bowl before and after and
in the middle of the Ebola crisis and
dr. Hani Marathi will talk about Syria
and some of the work that is being done
today at the moment to position them to
to better able to rebuild the health
system and they help education system so
professor
ask you first Rascals office and go
after noon and when you thank you very
much and hon thank you for organizing
this and for inviting me I'm going to
talk about Rwanda healthcare sector
Lebanon Baba Rwanda for about six and a
half years and it's really one of the
most hopeful sort of events that
happened after a major crisis and
somehow a country can rebuild despite a
major tragedy now wondering is a small
country about 10 million surrounded by
Uganda by Congo Tanzania and Ronde is a
landlocked country it's a beautiful
country with many many hills almost no
resources except for gorillas and
tourism that's basically I think I've
been lucky that they don't have any
resources as you can see this IE or now
Congo has been raped because they do
have resources
Ramana has none of that now the timeline
of Rwanda is critical to understand it
gained independence from Belgium in 1962
after that time between the two tribes
the Tutsis which form 15% Hutus which
form 85 percent population
Tutsis were really preferred by Belgians
they were more educated and when Belgian
left it was very clear that hoodoos were
going to be now the dominant force
taking over the government
so between 1970 and the genocide in 93
there were many small events happen some
were small genocides along the way
because of the conflict that was built
into the structure by colonialism and
during this time there was very little
that was really developed in Rwanda at
that time in term of calculus structure
many people emigrated almost all tooties
from Rwanda to countries near them
especially Uganda but some to Europe to
Belgium to France and so on so when
genocide happened which as you may
recall happened highly organized and an
evening of the president was killed
where when the helicopter was was
attacked in 90 days
10% population about a million were
killed so we're talking about a major
event happening in a very short time at
that time the Tutsi army that was in
Uganda headed by the president Paul
Kagame it came into the country to color
and then the post genocide the building
began obviously there was chaos in the
country because so many people have been
killed both the public structure private
extract had fallen apart and took
several years to really bring the
country back to some more emo normality
between 1999 and 2003 there were now
legislation elections and in 2003 the
Constitution was approved and part of
that was the idea of in a legal right to
health what in the Constitution now now
beginning a few years before that and
they had begun experiment in a small
area in some of the structure of the
healthcare sector and by 2003 2004 that
became a national model that we'll talk
about so the group that came back.the to
see that came back to call the country
basically
and any tribal identification so right
now we cannot ask anyone what tribe do
you belong to
but clearly because they were the one
that left the country have been educated
outside this fabulous Hakka see many of
the leadership are not Tutsis so there
is a still a major conflict that rules
under but the country is governed right
now if you go there it's quite safe and
it's really surprisingly it will run
contribute almost no corruption which
again is very surprising in is Africa
now what's the organization of the
healthcare sector it is highly
subsidized centralized so if it this
structure is defined centrally but that
is localized accessibility so that
individual can access healthcare at
their neighborhood level while the data
is generated collected centrally
organized are organized centrally it is
based on the focus of public health
preventive medicine rather than a
curative health because in networking
structure that covers the whole country
there's also no universal insurance that
really began with the experiments in
their late 90s this work on mutual which
is now covers all country two dollars a
head you buy insurance and that two
dollars a head allows you to then access
much of the preventive much of the
primary care the 16 percent lowest
income individuals who earn less than
about 50 cents a day they would not have
to pay the two dollars and that is free
to die group so their sexual health care
system is a pyramid with a large number
of health care workers at the village
level there's about 15,000 healthcare
workers is reflected by the elders go to
a very short term training they provide
preventive care much of it's a public
health vaccination following pregnant
women then there are about 400
neighborhood clinics
and health centers then district
hospital about 40 of them there's about
45 provincial hospital and founding 3
several hospitals in Kigali and in
Mutare so there's a network system where
there is a healthcare worker providing
care a local level nursing providing
much of the care in this record on and
then further on physician being involved
all the way from district hospital all
the way to the rural hospitals the
system allows you to actually move
across very quickly from it because a
patient visits outpatient and they
recognize you have a disease they cannot
manage you said very quickly to district
hospital you can then be referred to
prints on order referral a Sudan in this
emergency there's a way that you can
actually go all the way up to the front
of hospital very quickly so that's
highly again organized there's a very
interesting network of communication
using cell phone that allows that to
happen in real time now what is the
outcome of this system preventive public
health and then some to default as you
can see these are deaths in a thousand
live births
it went up dramatically the Green Line
that you can see at the time of genocide
it took a while and it's now actually
meeting the global health standards for
a lone low-income country much more than
many countries in sub-saharan Africa
that's also true of underside mortality
mortality primarily to respond disease
do Terrell disease drop dramatically
evenly from the year 2000 now to become
about a quarter of what it was if you
look at for example AIDS in Rwanda there
was a spike of deaths from AIDS again
around the genocide time took several
years before the most highly organized
so patient we're getting treatment now
the death rate has dramatically dropped
also in aids are shown by there
red line and as you can see the blue
line actually shows the number of
patients or untreated for
anti-perspirant treatment that
romantically increase in a present time
over a hundred thousand individuals of
wonder country of ten million who are on
antiretroviral medication this is
looking at malaria again the blue line
shows the rise again around the general
site time and now the mark drop about
over five years and the five years our
patient in patient malaria diagnosis and
finally if you look at TV are the major
screwed major cause of mortality in a
low resource environment because it
romatic decrease in work mortality from
TV in younger patient also in or all
population so that's been really a very
dramatic event has happened providing
care at the preventive network care to
the population this has resulted in life
expectancy increasing from 33 in 1990
before genocide to now double that 63 in
2012 and slightly higher now now one of
the thing that AIDS epidemic did because
it brought a lot of money to supplement
Africa from PEPFAR from Global Fund for
malaria aids and TV from other
organization they were left to build
many clinics around the country so
access secure became very easy for
patients with AIDS and require treatment
if you get any of the dogs with black in
the middle of it
those are the full-service clinics and
there's a large number of them the open
months are the ones that only provide
care to pregnant women to prevent
transmission to children now this clip
actually come in health center also for
men eight disease because of the
structure being at higher level higher
quality than the usual clinic in
sub-saharan Africa so they were able to
use really the front from eight to
really expand
primary care across the country
now one of the major issues in
healthcare other than having fun having
political will
it really relate to the number of health
care workers are available to provide
care nothing replaces that as you look
at the data in term of improvement in
health care half of it has to do with
improvement in economic condition the
other half has to do with human capacity
create knowledge and then to apply
knowledge within third policy being
preventive care building curious care
and more the major issues in sub-saharan
Africa is lack of human capacity and
this is now data to go to Rwanda it look
at the right-hand side of the slide they
have one to 15,000 one physician to
15,000 Asia in u.s. is 1 to 400 whi
recommends 1 to 10,000 as being in the
minimum more optimum one to two thousand
four thousand one to 15,000 very few
especially very few nurses for the whole
country and a health care system that
depends heavily on trained individual
forward provide care the number that
most looks like being an optimal number
income number of doctors nurses midwives
as you can see Africa has the highest
burden of disease that in Dali's has the
highest and the lowest number of health
care provider in the world compared to
let's say America or Europe by the ideal
number that really gets you there is
about 2.3 but Africa is very far away
from that number at about point 3 rather
than 2 point 3 health care workers for
the population and this is again the
referral system to again point out that
the major care is given by community
health care workers 40,000 at community
level but only 600 physician for the
whole country
now colonialism did not build
institution for Africa
these are the number of medical spas in
Africa as you can see around 1960 were
many countries were becoming independent
they were very few institution higher
learning to train health care workers in
Africa beginning with independence
mortal medical schools appear and
increase but still a number for the
population Africa is a very very small
number at present time so several years
ago Yale Medical portal to Rwanda
Michael is sitting there who headed the
group that went to Rwanda about six and
a half seven years ago trying to get
Yeley involved in improving his to serve
learning to Train healthcare works at
our time maybe about a year later one
word ago she ating Clinton Foundation
walked in they came in with a larger
idea and that became the project called
human resource for Health in Rwanda is
now at the end of the fifth year eight
medical school successful of Nursing one
school public health from Yale twist
columnar School of Dentistry began to
Train faculty every wonder for the only
Medical School run an usher University
School of Medicine Yale has been a major
part of this event the part of medicine
pediatrics / GYN in School of Public
Health have been playing a major role in
the design of this program exclusion of
this program present time this program
is unique in Africa because the fun is
controlled by African while the money
goes from us and from Europe to Ministry
of Health Minister husband independently
negotiates with Yale to a faculty from
Yale or responsible year to go there and
train faculty and this is now in the
sixth year and has a significant impact
I don't have time to show you the data
in terms of training of young physician
creating more School of Nursing the only
score dentistry in school of health
management all of that is the outcome of
this experience so this was used to
enhance a quality as well as a quantity
of physician nurses in the country
developing health management
training program at the level of master
degree increase number of medical and
nursing student but consistent or double
what it used to be increase the number
of postgraduate trainees in a specialty
areas the question really is that this
model called twinning model actually
worked in Africa and I will come back to
that it decided replace the fact that
you're still lacking resources to train
some specialist because a lack of a
deployed number of faculty a lack of
resources duda and sustainability is
your challenge so let me summarize what
I have been trying to in a sense tell
you about Rwanda which the Rwanda has
created a model it is really a model
that has been tried in other country in
Cuba the Rwandan model of healthcare is
very much a copy of the Cuban model
extending the same amount of money as
Uganda does there's a dramatic
difference between the data from Uganda
data from Rwanda so money is not the
only answer to the program's modernize
organization everyone has been able to
create an organization focusing on
critical aspects of health care
preventive care public health initially
and they're slowly not providing
high-level care at their referral
hospitals creating a network that allows
the patient to move from lowest level of
care to highest level in a fairly
efficient manner now creating a model
called twinning
to train faculty for the healthcare
institutions questions for somebody with
interested in capacity building is that
is tuning model work in other places in
Africa it is sustainable can it be
scaled up to the response to a low
number in a much more rapid time and
finally is it exportable election in my
colleague like a Christina will discuss
attempt export is now to Liberia where
this model is not being used but
modified and again the Yale is heavily
involved in that transfer
now to see if Liberia can use or want a
model to actually improve vehicle sector
let me thank you because any question or
available anti one step to Rustica one
second
are there any specific clarification
questions that you would want to ask any
about Wanda or I have one question
deciding on what the health system
should be the model is a very political
question right had we know that from
discussions in this country it's a very
so how were you part of some of these
discussions on what system is
appropriate for a for a country like
Rwanda and would they really go look at
model study models and then make a
decision or it's just how it came about
only Robin was really at the level of
how do you build capacity that was a
question that was posed to us so the
bottle was already there when we began
involved in the one of six years ago and
when you look at the country it was very
clear that Portugal me and the group
around him
came in with a plan he knew exactly what
he wanted to do from the beginning and
the order had to identify individuals
who would be heading different areas
these are individuals who have been
pushed out of the country but had become
highly educated Papago me in Uganda and
many of them actually in Europe so there
was a collection among them in terms of
what you wanted to when they enter the
country and what model they want to do
so the health care it took several years
for them to actually put together the
health care model but beginning before
the Constitution was approved for
several years they did experiment in
three locality in the country to see
would that model be access to the
population and the model was a network
water so by tender be arrived and water
was actually in place they should have
to do with
lack of resources human capacity to
actually improve the quality of the
treatment that they were giving at that
time and there was a question that was
posed to us as a mission also the
funding being controlled the Minister of
Health that the first and the second in
Africa that the funders being in us
primarily really yeah will control over
decision made in a sense in the world
one is not running yet the other ones
who are asking Yale or artwork or others
to come and do the job they negotiate
exactly what they need to do so they're
very much in control of what's going on
that has been a challenge but they have
learned a great deal by actually
managing this budget abuse project is
about 25 30 million dollars a year right
now a challenge for us better for them
probably but let's go into the next
speaker
hi everyone I'm Christina Calvert slagle
and I just want to echo dr. Ross cigars
thanks for having me here and for
inviting me I don't know where Helen
went but anyway it's very nice to be
here and I'm glad to have the
opportunity to discuss these important
topics with you so perhaps I can pick up
where dr. Ross cigar left off with this
idea of can a model of rebuilding health
systems as has been done Rwanda be
exportable to another country so I'm
going to talk to you today about Liberia
which is a post-conflict nation and also
as we are aware post Ebola nation as
well so Liberia is located in West
Africa it's a small country it's
geographically about the size of the
state of Tennessee in the u.s. it has
between three and four million people it
has 15 counties and as you can see the
flag of Liberia looks a great deal like
the flag of the United States and
there's a long history with the u.s.
Liberia was populated by the US
government with freed slaves that were
actually they hailed from all different
parts of Africa but were settled in
Liberia of course there were already
people there and so there was conflict
shortly after that and that led to some
of the laid some groundwork at least
according to some theorists and
historians for a civil war that began in
Liberia in 1989 and lasted for 14 years
a little bit of history before the
Liberian Civil War in the late 60s the
country specifically thinking about
health systems established there was a
hospital established John F Kennedy
hospital in the capital city of Monrovia
and also a medical college sponsored by
the Vatican and named after an Italian
surgeon named AM dog Leo d and that
College of Medicine was at that time a
leading institution
in the West African region so at one
point Liberia had relatively speaking a
strong health system and strong medical
training structure that was essentially
very very heavily damaged by the 14-year
Civil War the medical school closed
twice there's only one in the country
closed twice during this 14-year Civil
War period and so Liberia is a
post-conflict nation so I'm going to
talk about Ebola a little bit but this
all ties together and so I wanted to
give a little bit of history of Liberia
in between the end of the Civil War and
when Ebola struck Liberia has freely
elected President Ellen Johnson Sirleaf
who is just now completing her second
term as president and around 2007 the
Liberian government has made an
initiative to strengthen their health
system they introduced something they
call the basic package of health
services and the focus of that was on
basic preventive and curative services
and I'll show you a little bit of data
in a minute about how health outcomes in
the country were improved by Liberia
zone
national initiatives for health systems
rebuilding post-conflict in the
post-civil war period then in 2011
following on the basic package of health
services there was something called the
essential package of health services
that further there was focus on primary
care lots of effort made to rebuild a
health system post-conflict then Ebola
hit in 2014 and I'll show you a little
bit more data on that and now they have
again gone backwards in having a very
fragile health system but there's an
ongoing effort in the country to build
and rebuild really a resilient health
system so the frame is now in more
modern terms you hear a post Ebola but
it is also still very much post-conflict
so these data are from the Year 2012 a
little bit related specifically to Ebola
but as dr. Ross cigar was pouring
out on the upper left is doctors per
100,000 and you can see librarian had
very low numbers also you may have noted
in my previous slide I had 1 to 15,000
so these numbers are actually a little
bit hard to pin down and they vary
depending on source but at any rate
Liberia and the other two predominantly
ebola-affected countries had very low
doctor to population ratios weak health
systems in 2012 despite the mini robust
efforts made post-civil war to rebuild a
health system then et Cie there is a
build a treatment center beds required
and that's in the thousand so Liberia
needed in January of 2015 two thousand
beds and had you know 0.5 or 500 and
then the health spending per person in
Liberia is low relative to Spain and and
similar high-income countries so despite
many efforts post-conflict pre Ebola
Liberia still had a very fragile health
system and yet they had seen significant
gains so here under five mortality is
one good measure of health system
strength and you can see Liberia is
shown here in blue that they did have an
increase a little bump in under-five
mortality in the 90s but you can see a
constant improvement in lowering numbers
of under-five mortality in Liberia
actually it's the lowest of the three
predominantly ebola-affected countries
in West Africa and then also these are
all three countries the middle box here
is Liberia and some other measures of
strengthening a health system these are
so Family Planning is in blue you can
see these are all pre Ebola numbers
Liberia had increases in the percent
coverage of family planning in their
country and skilled birth attendants and
in immunization so the country was
slowly but surely rebuilding
post-conflict pre Ebola and then Ebola
hit Liberia in 2014 it started in Guinea
in December 2013
spread to Liberia and Sierra Leone and
was a major major setback for the
country in their health systems
rebuilding and capacity and the two
things have unfortunately been
hand-in-hand so as we I think are all
aware Ebola treatment requires
significant training of healthcare
personnel extensive personal protective
equipment Ebola people giving Ebola care
needed to be covered from head to toe
and have training not only in how to
give care but also how to put on and
remove that personal protective
equipment in order to keep themselves
safe from transmission and in fact Ebola
affected many health care workers we've
done some work directly with the medical
school some of the faculty there were
lost due to Ebola and even some of the
students so it was a major hit to the
country and a major hit to health care
providers who because it was already a
fragile system were not equipped either
in training or in actual palm farmer
calls it's tough equipment personal
protective equipment to be able to
protect themselves and give care to
their patients as a result these now our
data from you can see the first actually
that's a quarter 2014 compared a quarter
one 2014 but essentially over the year
of 2014 they saw a 50% drop in
deliveries in institutions people were
afraid to go to health care facilities
to deliver babies a drop in child
immunizations the medical school closed
again in 2014 schools closed and people
stopped going to work so it almost shut
down the country a drop in health care
services in just the month of August
alone and then you can see two-thirds of
the health facilities in the country
were closed so one of the things
actually let me just give some real
numbers Ebola a cost more than 11,000
lives in the three countries Liberia
Guinea and Sierra Leone and more than
4,000 people were lost in Liberia
alone which was a tremendous hit for
this little country and certainly for
the entire region but they have they
have gathered and shown the same level
of initiative and vision and commitment
that was shown post-civil war so this is
an investment plan if it says for
building a resilient health system in
Liberia and I don't know if you can read
the smaller text but it specifically
says in response to the Ebola virus
disease outbreak of 2014-15 and actually
this was written by the Minister of
Health and by senior leadership in the
Liberian government at night during the
Ebola epidemic they would do whatever
needed to be done during the day to try
to address the emergency and then all
the time are saying we have to we have
to recover we have to do better we have
to build capacity and they identified
this is a in my view a very impressive
document it shows a real strategic
vision it has benchmarks lots of data
and importantly it comes from the
country itself they identified three
high-priority areas as you can see here
and before I talk about those a little
bit let me talk about what this word
resilient really means so this is or at
least what I understand it to mean and
what I've heard people describe it to me
so Ebola for Liberia was a massive and
sudden shock to the system and what
happened to the healthcare provision
networks such as they were given that
they were fragile post-conflict was that
they turn to address Ebola itself
directly it became to the extent
possible an emergency response
healthcare system so the regular
healthcare needs of the population were
not being met so women who were
delivering babies as you saw from the
slide with the blue box were not
accessing health care facilities
vaccinations were no longer being
delivered the things I've told you so
this idea of resilience is to build a
healthcare system that can
simultaneously withstand a sick
we can't shock like Ebola and still
maintain regular health care preventive
and curative services and it's been an
interesting actually just a moment on
what it means to build resilience in a
health system how do you do this so
these three high-priority areas are
Liberia is answer to the question how do
we build a healthcare system that can
withstand shocks and still enable us to
meet the needs of our population for
ordinary regular health care services
the first one is a fit for purpose
health workforce so just as dr. Ross
cigar was describing this is health care
workers at every level of the system who
have the training and the motivation and
the skills and the support
institutionally to be able to do their
jobs so there are a lot there are lots
of benchmarks underneath this but this
idea fit for purpose you don't just hire
somebody to give care who may not know
how to do it you hire people who know
how to do it you figure out how to keep
them trained you figure out how they're
supervised so that they feel motivated
figure out how to keep them paid on time
fit for purpose re-engineering the
health infrastructure is really about
buildings and it's do we have the health
care facility that we need that can meet
the needs of the patient population
that's in our catchment area do we have
for example an Ebola isolation room many
hospitals had no process for isolating a
potential Ebola case and they've made
changes there there have been there's
been introduction of infection
prevention and control processes in
their institutions but this is also
about making sure they have the
buildings and structures that they need
to be able to support the provision of
health care and then the last high
priority priority area is strengthening
epidemic preparedness surveillance and
response so one major learning was how
can we see these shocks coming and be
ready for them and not have it shut down
or redirect our entire healthcare system
and this is all this is on on the web
people are interested you know I enjoy
reading this kind of thing but it's a
really impressive document
in terms of how does the country say
alright we were fragile before we were
rebuilding now we've had this tragic
setback we need resilient how actually
do we get there and then within the fit
for purpose workforce which is really as
dr. Ross cigar said where we at Yale
hoped to support the efforts of Liberia
and this is again part of their specific
vision and detail of how they want to
see this happen they've identified five
what they call cadres five categories of
healthcare workers and you can see them
listed here it maps actually quite
nicely I don't have the picture but to
the pyramid of the different types of
healthcare workers thinking of what's
happening at the local level even in a
very rural community in Liberia
community health workers who's there
that particular cadre builds a lot on
what Liberians themselves were able to
do to stem the spread of Ebola there was
a great deal of community education of
individuals who went out into their
community and specifically we're working
to educate people and and introduced
practices change burial practices to
prevent a spread of Ebola
for example they have this very cool way
they do a handshake and then a snack and
they change that and would shake hands
by thumping elbows instead so that seems
to be a small change but these were
things that happened right at the
community level how can the government
of Liberia tap into those community
health infrastructures and build that
component of their health workforce
health managers so this touches on some
of the things I mentioned about how to
keep people motivated how do they know
what their job is when they come to work
that day are their colleagues there are
they going to have a meeting to talk
about where they're getting their
supplies how does all that get
coordinated so that's one component it's
almost a behind-the-scenes piece of the
health workforce but it's about making
the system function properly so that you
have what you need when you need it
whether it's gloves or some sort of
personal protective equipment medication
you talk to your boss or your manager
and they tell you this is this is our
plan for the next six months
then registered midwives which is
specifically obviously about skilled
birth attendants that's been a priority
for Liberia for a very long time post
conflict and certainly post Ebola and
then physicians and physician
specialists we as I mentioned have been
talking with colleagues at the Seoul
Medical School in the country about how
to strengthen their physician training
and then our colleagues are also
thinking about how to help support them
as they build in specialist training at
the residency level so this is to try to
address slowly but in a sustainable way
the low ratio of physicians to
population in the country and then I
should mention just in terms of
exporting the Rwanda model it's been
really interesting and and very exciting
to come into this work and learn from
the way that things were done in Rwanda
and have this comparison to Liberia
where for example the government of
Liberia is not making the financial
decisions there are many other players
involved many other funders I think
there are many funders involved in
Rwanda as well but the decision-making
structure is a little bit different and
so it's been interesting to see that
also been interesting to see how
different academic partners elsewhere
come into these processes and how we can
support the vision there and be led by
people in country so I I think actually
I can stop there I think that's my last
slide yep and I don't know if we want to
well let's let honey do in the next 50
[Applause]
try to keep it short and keep it uh get
us as close as we can to that contract
but I can't promise a coffee break so my
name is Hannah mafia I'm faculty in the
department of emergency medicine and I
feel like a bit of a fish out of water
because I'm here speaking about a very
different case both in terms of
personnel doctor ser with decades of
thinking about how to do go will help
how to do education and global health
education institutionally
christena who has got lots of experience
in health care management and thinking
about these systems I didn't start off
wanting to think about health systems or
medical education in conflict it was
really I come from it more from the side
of both service delivery like actually
going to work in the field or or as a
consultant or researcher but I kind of
backed into it in the case of Syria and
I'll describe a little bit how so
there's a I don't know if this is
apocryphal or if it's real but there's a
quote attributed to hypocrite is that he
would become a surgeon should join an
army and follow it because so much of
the advances in medical education
specifically medical surgical education
do happen in wartime well because of the
spike in the number of cases that
individual physicians see as well as the
opportunity to challenge dogma and
sometimes be forced to practice a little
bit outside of your comfort zone or your
normal set of resources and be forced to
innovate so through that innovation we
sometimes develop new skills like
tourniquets to stop hemorrhage which is
the leading cause of death or
traditional is the leading cause of
death and war the idea of triage to
better allocate resources during war
even blood transfusion for resuscitation
we developed new groups of people new
cadres of workers so whether they are
the ambulance crews and EMS personnel
that started off in wartime and now we
have in our in our civilian life these
were people who are carried off the
battlefield by the drum and Fife Corps
they're like the people that were
military musicians they didn't have
weapons or anything to do during the
fight so they would go pick up the dead
bodies which is you can imagine a less
than ideal emergency transport system
but even the concept of structured
nursing and structured physician
assistance and physician extenders to
push skills that can be done by other
non physician providers down to a larger
number
people larger groups these are things
that we developed during wartime
and-and-and new tools that we certainly
didn't develop penicillin or antibiotics
because of war but the explosion and the
use of antibiotics actually really came
out of the experience of the words of
the early 20th century but and and and
of course you know new systems mobile
hospitals air evacuation etc but this is
all really different than what we're
talking about now these are all one-off
innovations where an individual or
groups of individuals are forced to come
up with a solution to a problem that
they are facing a very specific focus
problem medical education doesn't work
that way it's not about one-off
individual solutions medical education
is a system that requires a very long
lead time each each physician nurse
nurse practitioner resistances to what
have you community health care worker
they all require a certain amount of
background knowledge certain amount of
training that they'd received even prior
to their medical education and then a
very long time in training before they
actually are given the certification
that they're free to practice in most
cases this is more than a decade so you
can imagine the impact on our own health
systems when conflicts decimates their
their health health providers at or
force them to flee so unfortunately the
other thing that takes more than a
decade is the average displacement so
this is these are statistics from UNHCR
looking at the number of women and men
women and children who are displaced by
crisis around the world and you can see
that it's 17 years the average time
refugees are uprooted from their lives
these are UNHCR statistics these do not
include the Palestinian refugees that
are tracked through unruhe so and this
statistic of 34,000 people every day so
so we know that when conflict hits and
people are forced to flee whether they
are regular citizens or whether
their healthcare personnel the average
time that their life is disrupted and
they are unable to get back to where
they lived and where they and-and-and
they're worth 17 years right so it's
it's a fantasy
when these conflicts happen that they're
they're just on the edge of turning this
is about to turn around in a minute now
even if a war stops even if the Syrian
war stopped today right it would be
years before they had medical education
up and running in the traditional system
and it's been going for five to seven
years so you talk about essentially a
decade of absent health healthcare
health trained personnel we also know
that Syria itself this conflict is
different in its targeting of healthcare
workers explicitly health care workers
and health care facilities were
specifically targeted resulting in a few
intended effects one was actually
decimate the number of healthcare
workers as a form of intimidation one is
to force these people to flee and once
essential services are gone the thought
is that civilians will no longer remain
and and and we know the long-term impact
that I alluded to just before here this
slide is a illustration of what were 433
attacks on 297 individual health
facilities resulting in over seven
hundred eighty-six deaths of medical
personnel this is a project by
physicians Freeman writes where they
triangulate reports from each of these
points has to be triangulated by at
least two independent sources where they
describe both the numbers of the
circumstances the numbers of people
killed the the impact of the the strike
and if possible they indicate the
mechanism and and who were the actors if
not they simply say that they could not
verify and in terms of migration so
we're all familiar with the refugee
crisis now the worst in
more than a hundred years but the war in
Syria is impact on displacement of
healthcare personnel is also been
profound so it was estimated that there
were 31,000 physicians in Syria prior
and I apologize for not having all the
statistics on all the different cadres
of healthcare personnel but the
physicians were most readily accessible
and so more than half of them have been
displaced to other countries as refugees
and hundreds more I alluded almost a
thousand three hundred thousand that had
been confirmed as killed so we're
talking about a country that is heavily
heavily depleted of the roughly forty
percent that are left many of them are
in areas controlled by the regime
leaving the large swathes of the country
that are outside of the regime's control
to be in desperate need of health
personnel but Syria is also different
because of the ability for people to
communicate now the war started and they
had a complete collapse of the the phone
and Internet services throughout the
country specifically in the areas that
were in opposition held or opposition
control but what people have now that
they didn't have decades ago were these
so these are sold rather inexpensively
online and very expensively in Syria but
these are satellite phones that are up
links that basically allowed population
centers to communicate with each other
they allowed people to communicate with
family and and and professional
colleagues outside of Syria and they
allowed specifically the healthcare
facilities to communicate with each
other which was a game changer in terms
of the ability to reconstitute some of
these health networks and I have all of
these social media icons up here because
they too were used by people even though
it's extremely expensive to be on a
satellite internet connection that they
use these not just for socializing but
for actual patient transfer patient
communication and actually agency
medical education on an ad-hoc basis you
can see here this is I'm not going to
play this video again
much more gruesome than this but this is
a picture of the surgery being conducted
in the m1 hospital one of the trauma
hospitals inside Aleppo the reason that
they filmed these surgeries was not to
document the injuries or to say look how
amazing this surgeon is it was working
it was because certain hospitals were
seeing certain cases much more
frequently and they were able to video
the surgeries to be watched by medical
providers at other hospitals I see
medical providers because the person
forced to do the surgery in any given
Hospital right may not be a specialist
may not be actually a fully trained
surgeon they may be a resident who has
several years into their residency
training they might be assisted by a
medical student who technically has not
yet graduated medical school but has
been forced to undergo this kind of
conflict based continuing medical
education so as as I worked with this
network of physicians inside Syria to do
analysis of trauma data and as you are
going we would talk about the types of
patients we would talk about the
resources that they need and then kind
of afterwards when you're asking people
how they're doing you the subject that
keeps coming up is you know I'm really
worried about my young doctors I'm
really worried about my medical students
you know I've got three more that are
scrounging up tens of thousands of
dollars to pay some smugglers so they
can flood out in our after the
Mediterranean because they think that
their life is going to be better or they
they're losing hope about saying and
we're talking about people that are
incredibly resilient
these are people that were not the first
cadres to go they they managed to stay
behind despite extreme deprivation
extreme insecurity to themselves and to
their families even the ones who felt it
was unsafe for their families and forced
them to leave stayed behind to take care
of their communities but we're beginning
to lose some of that hope and and when I
asked I said what were what would be the
thing that would give you know these
medical providers who are already so
brave a little bit more light at the end
of the tunnel is that they said
well really their biggest thing is that
they feel that their life has stopped
that they essentially are trapped at
whatever level they were in 2010 or 2011
prior to the war and that there is no
hope for them and that there are no
mechanisms even in place to recognize
any of the work that they're doing now
such that they could continue on with
their lives as medical professionals in
the future and so that was kind of the
kind of social humanistic impetus behind
thinking about medical education in this
ongoing conflict setting but beyond that
there was a very practical need there is
a need to fill the pipeline for medical
professionals right so there was this
concept that oh the war is about to end
oh they they crossed Obama's red line
now the Americans are coming in oh and
there was every three to six months
there was some event that people felt
was a turning point that the war that we
can just keep going on on an ad-hoc
basis because the war is about to change
and now we can see you know going into
our sixth year that it's not about to
change and that and knowing that these
systems take ten years you really need
to start much much earlier and then
lastly there was by a few of us there
was this idea of trying to prevent what
is a war penalty for many people that
stay behind and take care of their
friends and neighbors during wartime
they frequently after the war find
themselves disadvantaged when people who
left at the beginning of a conflict go
abroad complete their medical education
get additional credentials when they
come back they tend in many previous
conflicts it was those people that the
returnees that filled positions in the
medical service walked people who stayed
just because there was no system to
directly address their condition found
themselves kind of lost between the
cracks so we talked and we talked to we
talked and then we kind of were apart
for a few months and I came back and I
said well what you know what what about
this idea they said oh we're already on
it and they relaunched Aleppo University
and they were actually faculty from
Aleppo University and they were very
intent on calling it Aleppo University
and they wanted to
at seed the the title and infra matter
of Aleppo University but I told them
you're going to need to partner with
people outside of your little group and
it's going to be too confusing to have
to aleppo universities you're going to
you're going to win out you're going to
win an award and get a grant and it's
going to go to the wrong team so they
you know agreed essentially at least in
English to call it the free Aleppo
University and you know this is not just
around medical school or health
education it actually encompasses
medical nursing they've got a class of
dental but then also humanities
engineering etc where they're basically
trying to provide a direction a future
direction for these hundreds and
ultimately thousands of students who are
graduating each year out of their system
so here's just a quick photo of FAU
Medical this is the Dean who is dr.
jihad who is actually a cardiothoracic
surgeon this is kind of an underground
area to avoid it because anytime that
the students come together they're at
risk of one barrel bomb could decimate
the entire medical school so they tried
to only come together in in areas that
are quite secure but you see them there
that's a microbiology class
so dr. Medina also goes by Abdullah geez
we we had him come to Yale a few times
and we said you know he gave
presentations on the condition in Syria
we said what what can we do to help and
and one of the the points that he made
at the end is is we don't want to live
as refugees anywhere in the world we
would like to go back and to our country
we want to rebuild our country we can
use technology with technology we can
deliver information to students and
those students will stay to lead their
health system what we just need to be
given the opportunity so with generous
support of several groups on campus
including global health Leadership
Initiative Mike's connect knees in the
back there and we counsel Middle East
Studies in the medical school we brought
some physicians from Syria actually and
video linked with other colleagues in
Canada in Europe in Turkey and actually
inside Syria along with faculty from
SUNY Albany to really sit around and say
what how can we address some of the
needs in terms of ongoing medical
education the challenge was to identify
ways that all of us could contribute in
a meaningful way to support this medical
education in terms of both NGOs
individual physicians and academics so
you can see here we actually had the
video link up directly with the students
at free Aleppo University so they were
able to participate in parts of the
discussion and their faculty were online
with us throughout so that we can make
sure that we were developing something
that was actually relevant to their
education and their circumstances so the
plan was to leverage technology for
medical education we wanted to make
English as a keystone skill because a
lot of the resources that were available
online to help do medical education are
in English unfortunately only and very
difficult to access Syrian medical
education currently has been done in
Arabic so we wanted to help provide them
some of these English skills to give
them access to these services and we
wanted to focus on basic science as a
critical gap we partnered with
organizations to look at some technology
solutions they don't they despite the
overwhelming number of dead bodies in
Syria there's not infrastructure
refrigeration electricity to maintain
proper anatomic dissection so our
students here hail use this visible body
program and ones like it to actually do
a virtual dissection we thought that
this was a good a good solution for FAU
as well
there's libraries Without Borders we
have a significant problem with
delivering information over the Internet
to a place that has such restricted
communications so libraries Without
Borders has a device called a kun book
where it is both a little server as well
as a little hotspot that delivers out to
20 to 30 individual
users so we are loading information and
lectures onto these devices to actually
deliver them to the decentralized
campuses of FAU so that the students can
actually continue these are these are
Yale students that have been part of
this effort and have really been pushing
this along and in partnership with our
partners the dr. Cameron our shell ie
from SUNY Albany they have a program
where they are actually able to do
developed take courses from the United
States translate them in Arabic deliver
them in partnership with the local
faculty in Arabic across the internet
now so I was telling this from MOOCs to
MOOCs so not just a massive open online
course but a massive open online course
in conflict right so the idea is to try
to match the tremendous global resources
but really do some of the work to kind
of shape things down to make it usable
for people under extreme circumstances
the students have been doing
peer-to-peer networks and and outreach
but there's a lot of work to be done a
lot of research to be done on the proper
implementation of this and and in terms
of the effectiveness the last very
unglamorous but I think a generalizable
problem here is the need for the
administrative grunt work ultimately we
need to find ways to make sure that
everything that is done now is properly
documented properly vetted properly
administered so that after the fact that
these all of this work can be recognized
we're not going to be a credentialing
Prudential body but we want to create
the materials that students and the
faculty can present to credentialing
bodies in the future I'm just going to
wrap up with a couple quick points here
so ultimately the process of rebuilding
it's got to start at the time of the
system breakdown right so in the
previous two presentations we were
talking about rebuilding healthcare
systems two-plus decades after those
civil wars right so you know I think
that we need to start thinking as
academics and humanitarian
of how we start doing these things from
the moment of breakdown so that we can
lessen the lag time in the gap we need
to establish some sort of recognition of
credentials and this is a general
general thing across not just for health
but even for high school students people
who leave they are one show one course
short of a degree they go to another
country they say I'm sorry we don't we
don't recognize your trends you know
please get us a notarized copy of your
transcript translated into our local
language and then you know we'll run it
by our credentialing committee these are
not feasible solutions for people
fleeing conflict and we need to have
ways of having some sort of recognition
of people's credentials both for
transitional use so that when somebody
is almost a vascular surgeon we can
recognize that they have those skills
and be able to extend the medical care
for instance in different regions and
distribute it more rationally and then
ultimately for people in resettlement to
be able to end them and then using
technology to crowdsource some of these
materials teaching online is challenging
I think it's a unique skill set I
learned that online teaching and
conflict is enormous Lee so but we're
still in the modelling and redevelopment
phase but this is really driven by
innovation passion of the students and
and there's a huge opening for academic
consortium to support health education
not just in this conflict but in
conflicts in the future I want to make a
plug because these students are
extremely deserving and there's this
fundraiser that we're doing right now to
help support purchasing these cool books
to deploy in the field and with your
permission I'm going to just use I'm not
control of it absentia
yeah I just wanted to show a quick video
here we're not going to watch all of it
but
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these videos are always shot from behind
and those women who are covering their
faces they don't they don't actually
normally cover many of these students
this is in a neighborhood just outside
of Damascus they're under siege their
families are live and work in Syria and
they're afraid of their identity kind of
being compromised and hurting their
family members so that's why there is
this this one guy said no I want to show
my face I want people to know kind of
what we're doing here and to understand
what we're doing so anyway I know that
we ran a little bit over time I
apologize but thank you for your
attention
all right three interesting now
approaches I know there are a lot of
questions I have many but I let you guys
ask the questions will take about four
or five and and then we lost the Pamela
so answer and then we'll see if we have
time for another round questions and
let's try to ask big-picture questions
no one no questions
oh boy all right I have a question
all right so this is for dr. Roscoe Garr
and whoever wants to answer it
history is made by victors so in a
country like Rwanda how do the losers of
the war how are they part of any
discussion around rebuilding societies
and rebuilding systems if whether they
are still going through a process of
maybe you can call it healing those who
are involving genocide have been tried
by their own community that's actually
still continuing this is not twenty one
or two years after the genocide so we're
talking about a huge population but
neighbors kill neighbors even genocide
are killing study family and all of that
so the process haven't finished really
and the country is the electronic
incense that various awards to choose a
president and Parliament but at the same
time you know that there's a lot of
control over society I've look for lost
I dunno doctor and mr. Paul Kagame was
here a couple of months ago and there
was also a class outside his speech of
those who look at him as being dictator
and those who thought that he was doing
reasonably well my feeling that the
country has gone
food that can reach other side there is
always going to be a lot of fire under
the ashes that are going to be going out
at this one especially because right now
when you look at the leadership clearly
is more Tutsis than Hutus marucho's on a
de facto population so the hope is that
that the issue will resolve over time
that the generations
forget about genocide building the
country that then there would be a
cohesiveness as being Rwandan rather
than being Hutus or Tutsis how quickly
that will happened a teen as an
experiment that's developing right now
and it's difficult to predict future but
if you look at what Wanda has
accomplished compared to other countries
we working in ganda work in South Africa
in Liberia clearly the one has made
major gains in education or certain
health care all of that was not being
democratically around and in a sense
being a country that is controlled by a
small number of higher echelon at this
point but at the same time this is true
that there is almost no corruption in
Rwanda which is really in Kabul Uganda
where corruption is very widespread in
regard one dollar you can work there
without will being concerned that the
funding is being misused that really is
unusual so that has occurred by thing
the process of feeling will take many
generations again another object leaders
questions yes Nicholas thank you very
much for a very very interesting set of
presentations Rwanda one of the
fascinating things that happened there
was the deployment of technology and the
rapid SMS system could you tell us a
little bit about how that is being used
particularly in terms of maternal
mortality reduction
one or two more questions any related
questions that
yes all right so let's and come on
technology I actually happen to be in a
meeting with President Kagame at one
time and the question was put to me is
what model are you developing your
country on and he said we want to be the
Singapore of exotica because we have no
resources no resource we have is human
power and technology would be the
support system so they really began
using that probably more effectively
than other places in a sense that there
is a great deal of data collected on
continuous basis in Rwanda so that their
health centers are connected to Ministry
of Health unusual basis so they report
malaria on daily basis new cases they
report any unusual finding during Ebola
event a student flew from West Africa to
Rwanda with fever and I'm in Kigali at
the time that same thing happen New
Haven by the way where the student came
back to New Haven from Liberia with
fever the same thing happened here
actually happened in Rwanda that that
person was immediate isolated
information with University of Health
and set of organization was created
immediately fortunately he did not have
Ebola nothing was resolved in three days
similarly here so they were really
highly organized centrally as I
mentioned but again the health care is
really decentralized to them
every level that requires a great deal
of communication between neighborhood
clinic district hospital all way up the
chain to refer the hospital they have
actually developed that but it's a smart
country but wonder you have the highest
density of population of any country in
Africa so we're talking about a tiny
place but because it's extremely hilly
is that easy to reasonably place quickly
so they so use of technology has been
very helpful in developing the
healthcare sector if you go to the
second question which is the usual
political world I think you see that in
interaction with people and I know you
and I met the mix of health doctor -
very powerful woman she knew exactly
what you wanted we are hired by the one
and our boss and we go there or the one
not and she clearly knew exactly what
you wanted to get done with your time
that this was going on I think that
really comes from above that you're
empowered to make sure that projects
meet deadlines and that no NGO is there
on their own you cannot go to Rwanda and
see the shop without being invited to
come in even I within one after
invitation to go in and do my work there
we gather the doors open you can walk in
any time serve anything so that is the
system in which the hydroxido has or
decide what model they want it transmits
further down there's a weakness
obviously that the discoveries from
lower levels doesn't trickle up very
quickly so that to challenge the system
has been difficult but where when it
works it works really quickly
Holly and cover
screaming but I but actually I'm
inclined to believe that it's really a
different model that and that model
hasn't really been developed yet because
I think you know they're coming off of
Michael's question these are very
long-term investments when you talk
about health education investments but
in the mid in the in the setting of
being post-conflict you can gather
stakeholders around and people can say
oh I'm willing to put that type of money
and I don't think that anybody Clinton
Global Initiative or anybody else is
going to put thirty million dollars a
year into free Aleppo University right
because it's seen as a highly unstable
environment and there's insecurity these
students are not even gathered in one
physical location like they're kind of
dispersed and even within the country
they are they're decentralized so I
think it's it'll be incumbent upon us to
develop other models we heard a little
bit in the morning about early travelers
education they're going to they're
trying to get Sesame Street to develop
materials to teach kids up to eight
right presumably not in a classroom
setting right that are displaced and
threw out so I think there's a lot of
room to be done in that type of
innovation of around education both in
health and other sectors
occasion I was just wondering if you
face any challenge introducing that
concept because in a lot of developing
countries the concept of preventive care
does not exist you only go to the doctor
when you're sick so if you see any
challenge and if so what were they my
second question about Syria in your
presentation you meant you show a
professor who when asked what can be
done he said I just want to build up my
country create opportunities I don't
want to be a refugee anywhere I don't
think any of the refugees want to be
refugees anywhere everybody wants to see
their country flourish to its highest
potential but in many cases people leave
their countries to go abroad they go to
school they go to medical school they
become lawyers they stay in those
countries the practice practice law or
practice medicine and they don't go back
to their home country so to what the
professor's say how can you motivate
those people to go back to their country
especially if you come from areas with
high instability
how can you motivate them to go back and
to contribute to the contrary to what
the professor said how can you answer
his question respond after the first
question and in one of the major
preventive care and public health area
is done by community health care workers
these are three individuals per village
selected by the elders who go through a
very short course this really focused on
sanitation or clean natal care on
following women who are pregnant up to
the end of pregnancy on vaccination as a
primary vaccination rate in Rwanda is
over 90 percent it's really the work of
the company health care what can I do
that they also are taught to the
diagnose two or three common disease
diarrhea in children for example fever
caused by malaria in adults and so on
then they should be patient quickly to
the higher level which is there
health centers at that time they model
developed in China called barefoot
doctors in the village I work in Iran
that was a model that worked in Iran so
this model has really been tested in
different places this is now on a very
larger scale than 14,000 covered
healthcare workers in a small country of
Rwanda and this week a credit for that I
would say very quickly I think what dr.
Harry was referring to is that it is
extremely difficult to get people to
return back once they've gone and spent
a decade getting training and
establishing their career abroad so he's
trying to change the conversation to be
I will stay here unless you know he
wants to keep the question at that level
rather than I will I might return if
right which is what frequently happens
when people have been displaced for a
real long period of time I didn't
realize it but I didn't realize that I
would be focused on this but I had a
classmate in my residency who was a
Liberian physician who was about to
complete her she was that person who was
one course short right she had she left
came to the United States had to start
over get a high school degree went all
the way through medicine or
undergraduate medicine residency so we
were colleagues in residency graduate
together miss Tina Mason she's an
amazing physician but when I think of
everything that she had to do to get
back to the level that many people don't
I think it's very hard then to tell
somebody to to necessarily upward their
life and go back especially if it's
remains insecure I would just say we've
also talked about this with Liberia
there's a huge Liberian diaspora that is
post-civil war many of them physicians
just like you said elsewhere and as we
talked about bringing people in to do
medical education it became evident that
once people are have established a life
somewhere and raising children it's
really very hard to get them to come
back but there may be ways that that we
can tap into that diaspora population by
for example connecting
through some of these technological
innovations students in country to
medical faculty who are Liberian who
live elsewhere or one of the things
we've talked about this is just an idea
at this moment but you know an endowment
for the Medical School in Liberia I
think that's maybe not possible in the
midst of conflict but now it might be
possible where alumni who live elsewhere
and are not going to come back can still
contribute in a way that would
contribute internally in country to
building the system and improving the
medical education there so some creative
solution so a couple of concluding sort
of thoughts brain drain is a serious
problem right in all of these countries
affected by conflict it's the most
educated who leave first but forcing
them back is not a solution I think
ultimately what they need to return is
law and order and some sort of
opportunity for themselves and their
children and you know their family once
that is in place people will
automatically add things start going
back now
this I mean I have a lot of questions to
ask but I won't but perhaps there is a
case to be made under McMillan or maybe
together with the School of Public
Health to somehow document these stories
to sort of learn what were some of the
key ingredients that make those
particular interventions successful
because we still don't know there's a
lot of expectation on humanitarian
agencies to deliver but that's only one
side of the coin as we've heard from the
Rwanda case government determination
political will knowing exactly what they
want not letting other people kind of
boss them around all of those are very
important considerations and we could
perhaps contrast that is what's with
what's going on in Liberia today where
everybody has a say in what Liberia does
right so I think there is a lot of
lessons we can learn and perhaps under
this new program we should you know talk
to start a document
and sort of understand these dynamics
much better thank you you wanted to add
something okay yeah very quickly I'm
thinking about political will in Liberia
the the story there was they were trying
to rebuild their health system
post-conflict and then Ebola got the
world's attention that the health system
needed to be rebuilt and so there's a
lot of conversation now about this kind
of potentially preventable crisis having
been something that could have been
foreseen and all the investment for
Ebola now how can we use how can we
capitalize on that moment and the
awakening from the emergency to think
longer term so one thought on Macmillan
is you know there are short-term
problems and then there are long-term
problems and how do we think about
resilience the way that the Liberians
have cast it where you both can manage
an emergency but also think longer term
rather than just continuing to respond
to emergencies fantastic so without
losing much time I'd like to invite
professor in home to come and deliver
lecture no coffee break you're welcome
to step out get coffee and come back
[Applause]
[Music]
you